[Musique]
et on vous retrouve désormais chaque
jour à schreinte Jean bonjour on est à
moins d'un mois il faut le dire du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ici en France oui j moi
27 du premier tour de la présidentielle
et la campagne vit toujours au rythme de
la guerre en Ukraine et de ses
conséquences sur le quotidien des
Français a commencé par l'impact sur les
prix des carburants toujours au dessus
des 2 euros le litre en moyenne même si
en ce début de semaine l'essence et
surtout le diesel ont connu une nette
baisse alors que le gouvernement a
annoncé samedi une remise de 15 centimes
sur le litre d'essence la plupart des
candidats ont appelé à diminuer les
taxes sur les carburants relançant ainsi
le débat sur cette fiscalité jugée
particulièrement injuste leur récap
politique de la semaine est signé
Florent rodo et Lucie Latour
c'est l'histoire d'une campagne à minima
bien plus président que candidat
Emmanuel Macron s'affiche avec les
leaders européens pas le temps en
revanche de se rendre à son propre
meeting à Marseille il envoie ses
lieutenants en renfort
qu'il faut convaincre avec humidité que
nous avons je crois le meilleur bilan et
que président de la République et celui
qui est le mieux placé pour diriger la
France dans le contexte que nous
connaissons mais il faut convaincre avec
le candidat et parfois sans lui
la guerre en Ukraine pèse sur la
campagne sur le pouvoir d'achat des
Français aussi le gouvernement annonce
une remise de 15 centimes par litre
d'essence dès le premier avril et
électoraliste pour plusieurs candidats
insuffisant pour d'autres je persiste à
dire qu'il faut baisser de manière
pérenne la TVA sur l'énergie de manière
générale je propose que l'on supprime
provisoirement la TVA sur le carburant
moi je souhaite que le gouvernement
s'engage à rendre tous les surplus de
recettes fiscales qu'il a aux Français
sur l'essence à gauche Nathalie
artosagas contre les géants pétroliers
grands profiteurs de la crise selon elle
de la station-service elle a pas été
payée au prix du baril de
d'il y a deux heures ça s'appelle de la
spéculation
malgré les apparences
il n'est pas vraiment à la fête visée
par une enquête pour emploi fictif
Fabien Roussel n'a pas l'intention de
jeter l'éponge
je savais bien qu'en suscitant une
certaine sympathie et même une dynamique
autour de la campagne que je porte qu'il
y aurait une partie de ball-trap qui
serait ouverte les coûts tombent mais je
vous le dis rien ne me détournera de
cette campagne le communiste se prend
une enquête quand Éric Zemmour lui se
prend un œuf
coup sur la tête ou pas il fait
volte-face aimer de côté sa mesure phare
l'immigration zéro il promet désormais
des visas au cas par cas
pour finir ces images de Valérie
Pécresse en Corrèze terre de son mentor
Jacques Chirac nouvel opération
séduction du monde rural pour tenter
d'enrayer sa chute dans les sondages
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et première grande soirée électorale
c'est ce soir à l'enversaire de la pub
pour nous confrères de TF1 ou 8 des 12
candidats vont non pas débattre mais ce
succéder s'exprimer à leur tour sur
justement la guerre en l'Ukraine et ses
conséquences ici en France oui un format
Raphaël qui suscite un certain nombre de
critiques les petits candidats comme
Natalie Arthaud de Lutte Ouvrière
Philippe Poutou du nouveau parti anti
capitaliste ou encore Jean Lassalle du
parti résistons s'indine d'en avoir été
exclu par ailleurs tous les adversaires
d'Emmanuel Macron dénoncent le refus du
chef de l'État de débattre directement
avec eux avant le premier tour écoutez à
ce sujet Valérie Pécresse
je pense que les débats sont éclairants
parce que je pense que les débats
permettent de démonter les programmes
quand ils sont quand ils sont illusoirs
parce que les débats permettent aussi de
faire le bilan d'une action et je pense
que Emmanuel Macron ne peut pas échapper
au bilan de ce quinquennat et que la
crise ukrainienne ne peut pas
comment dire nous nous faire
priver les Français du débat
démocratique auquel ils ont droit
l'un des impacts de cette guerre en
Ukraine c'est l'arrivée de réfugier en
provenance du crâne un rythme jamais
observé depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en Europe cent mille par jour
conséquence et bien cela s'invite dans
la campagne présidentielle au total on
estime à 2700 000 personnes le nombre de
personnes ayant fui la guerre en Ukraine
parmi elles 50000 à 100 000 devrait
arriver en France dans les prochaines
semaines selon le gouvernement on en
parle ce soir avec vous Charlotte
boittiaux bonsoir je le rappelle vous
travaillez pour le site info migrant de
France 24 spécialisés justement sur les
crises migratoires en Europe les
différents candidats à la présidentielle
française ont bien été obligés ces
derniers jours de se repositionner ou de
se positionner tout court d'ailleurs sur
cette nouvelle crise migratoire au
risque parfois de se déjuger oui tout à
fait depuis le 24 février les candidats
sont un peu obligés de réorganiser leur
déclaration car évidemment la guerre en
Ukraine a changé la donne notamment à
l'extrême droite qui a toujours porté
cette ligne 0 immigration et pourtant
Marine Le Pen a déclaré le 25 février
sur BFM qu'il fallait bien sûr
accueillir tous les réfugiés
Ukrainiens qui souhaitaient venir en
France une position qu'elle n'avait ni
eu pour les Syriens ni pour les Afghans
qui ont pourtant subi donc la chute de
Kaboul par les talibans on l'écoute
c'était sur France 2 le 3 mars dernier
la question vous avez été posée il y a
quelques semaines sur les femmes afghane
vous avez dit non il me semble non il ne
faut pas accueillir les femmes afghanes
il n'y a pas de guerre en Afghanistan
c'est terminé c'est terminé
bien sûr mais il y a pas de guerre
voilà alors cette différence de
traitement est assumée par la candidat
du Rassemblement national qui estime je
cite qu'il est naturel que les pays
européens puissent accueillir les
réfugiés en provenance de guerre de pays
européens toujours à l'extrême droite de
l'échiquier politique l'ancien polémiste
Éric Zemmour lui tente de rester fidèle
à sa ligne 0 immigration le candidat de
reconquête préfère donc que les
Ukrainiens soient en Pologne plutôt
qu'en France
Eric Zemmour de son propre aveu préfère
éviter un tsunami migratoire basé sur
l'émotion le 28 février sur RTL il
déclarait je préfère qu'il soit en
Pologne la Pologne et leurs voisins ils
pourront donc plus facilement rentrer
chez eux quand la guerre sera finie ce à
quoi la journaliste lui répond vous
seriez donc le seul candidat à ne pas
accueillir des réfugiés si vous le dites
j'assume des déclarations pointées par
sa que des batteries sont la semaine
dernière la candidate les républicain va
la ipcresse qui taxe d'inhumain le
candidat Éric Zemmour oui inhumain
esprit mun pas Valérie Pécresse n'a pas
mâché ses mots pour tacler son rival
pour elle il n'y a aucune ambiguïté
quand elle accueille des réfugiés
Ukrainiens sur le sol français il faut
que la France ouvre ses portes à
condition toutefois que qu'il ne ces
nouveaux arrivants ne soient que des
Ukrainiens car la candidate des
républicains elle fait bien la
distinction une distinction un petit peu
hasardeuse entre ce qu'elle appelle des
vrais réfugiés et des faux réfugiés
c'était dans une tribune du Figaro je
cite toujours si la situation l'exigée
écrit-elle je souhaiterais que la France
manifeste sa solidarité en accueillant
des réfugiés
Ukrainiens bien davantage que les faux
réfugiés qui sont indument entrés en
Europe ces dernières années donc faut
réfugiés faux réfugier désignant pour
Valérie Pécresse un des des surement des
migrants économiques qui ne devraient
pas être éligibles à l'asile ou qui
n'aurait tout simplement pas dû avoir
l'asile et à gauche Charlotte qu'on dise
les candidats alors à gauche les
candidats se déduisent peu de leur
programme initial globalement de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à Yannick Jadot en
passant par Anne Hidalgo tous sont
favorables à l'accueil des réfugiés quel
que soit leur pays et quel que soit leur
religion l'Ukraine ne fait pas exception
et les candidats de gauche d'ailleurs
prônent tous une ouverture des
frontières et s'engage à améliorer dans
leur programme la prison charge des
réfugiés qui sont déjà présents sur le
sol français et quant à Emmanuel Macron
le président candidat il a été peu
volubile sur le sujet il a sobrement
déclaré la semaine dernière que la
France prendra sa part ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le président a lancé
exactement la même phrase l'été dernier
à propos de l'Afghanistan la France
continuera de faire de faire son devoir
pour protéger celles et ceux qui sont
les plus menacés nous prendrons toute
notre part avait-il affirmé avant
d'ajouter que la France devait aussi se
protéger contre des flux migratoires
importants donc accueillir se protéger
une précision qu'il n'a pas eu cette
fois pour l'Ukraine merci beaucoup
Charlotte du site info migrant de France
24 je le rappelle votre équipe suit au
quotidien la flux de réfugiés Ukrainiens
notamment en Pologne en Roumanie et
Hongrie de nombreux reportages sont à
découvrir sur votre site malgré les
constats alarmants c'est la grande
oubliée pour l'heure de cette campagne
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique à cheval oui la guerre en
Ukraine n'a pas aidé à mettre ce sujet
sur le devant de la scène en tout cas ce
thème reste une préoccupation majeure
pour les Français ils étaient d'ailleurs
près de 80000 à défiler hier pour
remettre l'urgence climatique au cœur de
cette campagne Maya Anaïs yatagen était
sur place regardez son reportage
plus qu'un mois avant l'élection
présidentielle mais si l'horloge tourne
c'est surtout pour le climat
ces milliers de personnes exigent que
les candidats lève enfin les yeux au
ciel tel Léonardo DiCaprio dans le film
donc Luc up métaphore sur l'inaction
face au dérèglement climatique le sujet
déjà peut présent dans la campagne a été
éclipsé par la guerre en
ukrainement
en tout cas sur ce qui est possible
d'anticiper dans plusieurs gens et on a
l'impression que même des faits
scientifiques ça fait pas bouger grand
monde dont la foule plusieurs candidats
de gauche dont Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
prône une planification écologique
regardez dans les programmes ce qui leur
paraît être à la hauteur des
circonstances vous voyez je suis sympa
je dis pas que c'est yak le mien qui
répondent qui est pourtant la vérité
l'écologie Jadot à lui aussi braver le
crash un Parisien il propose un quoi
qu'il en coûte climatique confirme sa
volonté de sortir du nucléaire et de
mettre fin à la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles avec toutes les complaisances
politiques que ça génère ça la
démocratie on le voit en Ukraine ça tue
les gens mais ça tue aussi le climat
Anne Hidalgo à quant à elle taclé le
bilan d'Emmanuel Macron nous sommes
gouvernés depuis cinq ans par un
président qui a tourné le dos à la
question du climat qui a considéré que
ce n'était pas un sujet qui d'ailleurs a
été condamné dans son propre pays par
une des plus hautes juridictions le
Conseil d'État pour son inaction
climatique selon une récente étude le
climat est un enjeu jugé capital par 94%
des Français notamment les plus jeunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on finit comme chaque jour en
fouillant dans nos archives avant l'oeuf
envoyer sur
Eric Zemmour à Moissac et bien il y a eu
des précédents dans la politique
française
alors Emmanuel Macron et parmi d'autres
un habitué des œufs ici vous le voyez
c'était à Lyon en septembre 2021 il y a
aussi l'enfoirinage devenu un grand
classique François Hollande en a été
victime en pleine campagne en février
2012 Jean-Luc Mélenchon également en
juin dernier dans une manifestation
parisienne ou encore on va le voir
François Fillon voilà en 2017 lors d'un
meeting de campagne aussi et enfin
l'incontournable Raphaël tarte à la
crème on a donc distingué il y a
quelques secondes François Bayrou a en
déplacement de candidat lui aussi à
Rennes en avril 2002 voilà Raphaël c'est
tout pour ce soir
les candidats eux-mêmes et on peut les
comprendre merci à shred c'est la fin de
France 2002 la fin de France 2002 pour
aujourd'hui puisque l'heure du choix
2022 lala on vous attend plus tard on se
retrouve en tout cas demain pour notre
journal de campagne désormais quotidien
et nous dans 3 minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans parisien